when I talk about solution selling and
kind of providing solutions to your
clients everybody thinks you hear I need
a react engineer you say great I've got
a react engineer that's not solution so
like we've got to identify a pain Point
like a thread pull up that pain point
until there's no thread left and you
fully understand the problem what
happens if the project doesn't get
delivered on time what's the knock on
effect of that why is the project
running behind I'm not just providing
you engineer cuz you said you need an
engineer I'm providing you an engineer
with the specific skill set that is the
skills Gap or that is the problem and
you've taken five minutes to explain to
me what implications it has on your day
to-day and what the opportunity cost is
by not hitting these X goals